that's like when you go to like the
Midwest and a lot of people dip out
there like college guys and then at frat
parties there's always like a dip cup
and then people are always like no don't
drink is the dip cup you ever seen that
[__] videos people drinking
disgusting bro I want to try this
[Music]
all right we got some New Zealand news
you've been there right I've not been to
New Zealand I've been to Australia oh
I've been Australia too man who have you
here's been to New Zealand I haven't
been to New Zealand damn I would love to
that's like the next step you got to go
you know you go to Australia and then
it's like then you go to New Zealand how
long is that flight to New Zealand from
Australia
from here from here [__] far there's
no direct flight to New Zealand maybe
from Hawaii I think from Hawaii there
might be oh yeah maybe yeah I did it
nice well future generations of new
zealanders will be banned from
purchasing tobacco as part of a package
of a new anti-smoking laws that's past
Parliament on Tuesday and among the most
strict in the world so if you were born
on or after January 1st 2009
punishable by fines of up to 95 000 you
will never be able to buy tobacco I like
that that's because they're like yo you
need to start vaping kids that's dope
it's for their own good yeah go get some
strawberry Vape hell yeah man don't get
caught up in that [__] yeah go get
some cantaloupe there's no benefits
besides looking real [__] cool
damn it does look pretty that is huge
though like that you're [__] up the
kid's ability to look [__] but new
zealanders already look cool they are
kind of cool already dude
yeah dude those only work when you're
smoking tobacco though you know what I
mean yeah they always got Lucy hanging
out while they're [__] playing so is
everybody just gonna hive mind this
video and that's it you know what dude I
love tobacco I think it's [__] great
do you think they should still have the
freedom of choice though
I thought in New Zealand they're giving
out math and [__] I don't know what it
is you know New Zealand's giving out
meth yeah I heard that like if you're
addicted to meth and stuff they just
keep you off the streets they keep you
in the house and they're like here's a
little myth stay out damn yeah I think
they have to so you can keep you alive
because when if they do a hard if you go
uh cold turkey you can get sick and die
oh I'm sad what on the street that's a
set in Sacramento San Francisco well I
want math users to live forever though I
don't know much about New Zealand but I
do know that during covid they were able
to be open because they didn't let
nobody come in
so they're just like let's just they did
a good job man they're just like working
out they were chilling dude they didn't
have to import cigarettes yeah so
they're like we just won't let people
come through come inside and then
they'll just chill I think if you're a
beautiful place like that that's
isolated in a way do what you can man to
keep it nice but imagine you were
visiting can you leave and go home or
you're stuck in New Zealand they say get
the [__] out of here kiwi now yeah kiwi
I would assume you could leave but I'm
guessing once you leave you can't come
back go parents rule I don't know man I
want to go there because it looks
beautiful it does look beautiful it's
where the shot Lord of the Rings and
[__] it's like Hawaii but then all the
Polynesians have this weird accent that
make them seem like distinguished
gentlemen
they all sound like do they got Korean
barbecue there though I can't go
anywhere with no print box true that's
true what's up with that I like cream
barbecue too much let's check out you
want me to check yeah go on yeah and
make sure look at the menu if they have
Gabi is there a Korean barbecue in New
Zealand so when they were keeping people
out how did they get stuff in like when
they would still import stuff in and I
think they gotta stop them in the water
put on a raft and then push it to me yep
10 10 best Korean barbecue in Auckland
New Zealand yo they got Korean barbecue
dude I could live there I could live
there they got Bond songs they got red
pig they got farro they got sansu gobsan
they got paldo Korean Buffet yo they got
Korean barbecue dog we could survive
there here's the question though do you
think if they made it illegal to buy
cigarettes would that just fuel the fire
for people that want to smoke more
because it's something you shouldn't do
and then it turns into the drug Market I
could get black markets want to quit
eventually and that would right there
make them quit because I don't think
anyone smokes now they're addicted of
course it's easy access I think if they
want to quit go there you can't buy it
anyways so you're eating someone's ever
going like I'll suck your dick for
somebody
this uh this band remains in place for a
person's entire life if they're born on
or after January 1st 2009 if you were
born in 2008 you can buy cigarettes oh
interesting like you old [__] can smoke
your life today are they just kind of
squeezing people out but it shouldn't be
that hard to get someone to buy you
cigarettes right yeah no but the the
industry is going to die out that's what
they're trying to do yeah phase out the
industry there's no benefit for smoking
for 95 000 I don't think I'd smoke a
cigarette like I'm gonna have someone
pocket cigarette what about all the
Philip Morris employees don't they need
jobs oh yeah we're not thinking of the
big picture man yeah man but it's gonna
happen to their jobs what about the lung
doctors
they're gonna be out of a job on the
poor lady what about the mortuary
did you use the smoke back in the day
cigarettes no do you guys want to start
you never smoke cigarettes just for fun
like a cool guy I would only like you
know socially chain smoke them when
you're like at a rave or something you
know it's funny you you look like
because you're cool you look like you
smoke you look like you smoked I know
but I try to look like that yeah but you
default look like a like I would because
I was gonna ask you if you wanna but
then I realized shut the [__] up because
you're cool cool you're a beauty guy
dude people that look cool look like
they you know they got a little bit of
back in high school a bunch of the
homies used to always smoke Black and
Milds and then we would like smoke with
them yeah and they're kind of tight dude
they smell so good it smells real good
man I kind of like them the way that
we're reverse [__] so hey you got no
Hive mine here I kind of like I kind of
like a cigar I like cigars it's a little
mouthpiece oh you know what's good
though a good [__] hookah session
dude you you get some mint tea you feel
like you're in the [__] Middle East
just sipping minty hookah's pretty cool
and you [__] we're talking and then
you have a long conversation
what's the most you used to smoke like
per day
I think I got up to pack one pack yeah
that's expensive yeah but that was like
when cigarettes were like five bucks
what is that is that like 30 cigarettes
in a pack or something what are they at
now like the average price of the pants
like of a regular Marlboro Red what's
that like 26 bucks oh is it I have no
idea I thought it was like 10 bucks now
I never bought a pack of my life let's
see uh right now some places are like 20
bucks depends on what state you're in uh
you can depending you can get packs and
then they get Cheaper by the pack the
cartons the cartons sorry 11 bucks
roughly wow it was double one package of
Marlboro cigarettes in Los Angeles is
about eleven dollars a pack is 11 bucks
yeah it used to be 380 dude it used to
be [__] cheaper than that and if you
got it from Mexico because people would
smuggle cartons of oh [__] that would be
like two bucks yeah a pack or you can
get it really depends there's a lot of
fluctuation on prices here you can even
get them for like seven bucks somewhere
or eight bucks nine bucks whatever Joe
you ever roll up a pack of cigarettes up
in your sleep leaves
no that's cool man do you remember that
old commercial where they would pack it
yeah yeah and they'd just be that was
like don't smoke or you and then they
would they would do it don't smoke we're
gonna look cool like these guys yeah
they do have monkey packing it and
they're like that's what you look like
is it because it looked cool that's why
how people I was so curious about
all those things drinks smoking because
it was illegal and I was like why so I
don't understand why people younger
can't do it but people older could do it
I just didn't get why that was a law so
I was like let me try and then like I'll
try beer and I'm like oh this is
disgusting but I can see why people like
it but I didn't know I was allergic to
alcohol so I was just like yeah it makes
people like buzzed and then I was like
cigarettes though I don't get it like
and everyone back then was smoking like
I remember when you take a plane ride
there was a smoking section when you go
into restaurants there were smoking
sections everybody was smoking so it
wasn't like shunned upon right there was
just like you're a [__] kid don't
cuss don't smoke you're not old enough
yet
so me and my buddies were just like oh
that's a cigarette on the ground it's
like it's like it's like half smoked
let's try this [__] we got a lighter we
lit it up and then we're just like
watching it go like burn and then you're
like you smoke it all right I'll smoke
it and then I was like oh this is
[__] nasty right and then like one
time um my friend's brother they're all
skating in there just like what the hell
you guys doing that's disgusting like
here and then you had a pack of
cigarettes and then so he was like take
take a clean one you know and then so we
pulled one out and then so we're all
like smoking and then we're all doing
this
we don't inhale right yeah and then he's
like inhale it and I'm and we're like
what and then they're like no [__]
take a breath after you pull it and then
so he taught us how to smoke and then so
we all inhaled it
we're all [__] coughing and all of
the brothers are like laughing at us
right and none of us want to look like a
[__] so we're just like yeah inside
you're done and so now we all get on our
skateboards and there's like eight of us
going down the street with cigarettes on
our [__] mouth like coughing while
we're smoking like we're [__] cool
but then it makes you um
kind of high and like weird but you just
keep doing it and it's disgusting but
everyone around you is doing it and then
afterwards you know you you smoke weed
and then you like the cigarette taste
while you're smoking and you just gets
you get hooked yeah yeah have you guys
seen do you guys have any friends that
like Vape all the time yeah yeah and
don't they [__] hit that [__] all the
time yeah it's so it's so accessible and
it like it the smell isn't as bad it's
very pleasant so it's like they hit that
way more than a regular cigarette dude
there's some people that you could tell
they're like Matt Hook like especially
with the with the studios that I have we
don't allow vaping inside and sometimes
when people get there they're like hey
he's a cool five eight in here and if I
say like oh no you can't some people
will visibly go they'll like winch
they'll be like dude one of my clients
this [__] he's like a boxing
club and this dude brings a vape in and
he starts hitting it I'm like bro you
were not hitting this Vape in the gym
right now this is crazy yeah and he goes
oh come on man like let me and I was
like nah dude like get the [__] out of
here with that you can't be smoking a
vape in here and then he puts it away
and I look back and he's [__] hitting
it I'm like dude are you [__] junkie
you can't take that [__] outside bro
that's ridiculous but he's he [__]
he's gotta have his [__] fix when
vaping first came out though it was so
cool because there was no rules against
it so then instead of smoking you just
you're at the casino and you just hit
that Vape or like you could just was you
know non-smoking casinos right like in
the poker table or like you'll be at a
restaurant just hit that [__] and then
people be like oh what is that that
smells like strawberries and like people
weren't against it even in Planes
remember that [__] people hit the Vape
in the plane and [__] that's just nice
yep and when people Vape around me I'm
like what's that mango Moroccan mint
hook me up dude dude when the [__]
first Vapes were starting to really come
out and they were like the giant ones
right you would see a giant cartridge of
liquid huge batteries you see people
[__] like twisting these giant
batteries on you hit it and it'll be
like burning the [__] out of your throat
and you hear it burned you feel the
bottle it's just it was like Cloud
[__] competition and they do tricks
with it yeah oh dude get a life get
along the [__] life dude that's just
crazy though you know what I mean you
think about like that era which was not
long ago yeah I get the appeal though
because like I I use a stizzy I used to
but like when I would hit it it would
get way more addicting and like way
easier and accessible to just to like
pick it up and be like oh [__] and then
sometimes when you don't use it you'd be
like oh I really want to smoke this
right now so it becomes like this habit
that you do over time and then that you
have to be like oh [__] this is it's
like with anything that becomes routine
yeah it's hard to stop yeah it becomes a
part of like your ritual of how you
relax and chill it's like it's not good
I used to dip you guys ever dip I wanna
you wanna start dipping I'll dip with
you I thought that I used to eat Big
League Chew like I was dipping you're in
pain but you keep doing it you're in
pain from it yeah in the ball you're
living does it like like a stings a
little yes cut itself but for some
reason that that addiction just like you
said you keep coughing but you just want
to do it it's like dude why can't I
sound crazy dude yeah the military hella
people dip and everyone has to keep like
a spit bottle everywhere though
everyone has it because it's all filled
up with nasty ass tobacco slime it's so
gross but I'm like
dry that's like when you go to like the
Midwest and a lot of people dip out
there like college guys and then at frat
parties there's always like a dip cup
and then people are always like no don't
drink is the dip cup you ever seen that
[__] videos people drinking
disgusting bro I want to try this not as
bad as two girls one cup though for sure
you want to put that to the test let's
do it
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]